okay one last one the endangered
innocent the endangered innocent as I
was pointing out earlier I was talking
about the wives of the astronauts they
were they that's their function they're
endangered innocents they are the story
goal they are the ones that need to be
saved and that is a story goal too in
they are in imminent danger of death or
loss and the stakes have to be nothing
less than that as high as stakes can be
for whatever story you're telling and
can be one person or a group
yes provides a strong subplot an
enormous ly strong subplot must be
sympathetic what must be sympathetic
they are provides a ticking clock and a
ticking clock we will come and refer to
again and again that is really important
they usually start at the midpoint the
ticking clock but it means time is
running out to accomplish whatever it is
the hero is out to accomplish the
ticking clock zero hour is approaching
get on it and make it happen okay my
example for you here is Kevin the bird
in up he is the endangered innocent Carl
and his friends have escaped from evil
adversary Charles Muntz is cave and and
his nasty dogs who are his adversary
agents and now they continue pulling
Ellie's and Carl's house this last short
distance to Paradise Falls he's almost
there is almost an accomplished his task
Kevin when their escape from you know
the previous escape kevin has been
wounded kevin was was basic to their
escaping at all and and and was wounded
so she's bandaged and resting on the
steps Russell tells Carl about the happy
times he had with his dad but they were
but they're far into few those those
happy times and the boy is clearly
needing a father figure and he's Russell
more and more with
adventures together he tried to dismiss
him in the beginning but more and more
Carl is falling for Russell and seeing
Carl's immediate today needs as weighed
against the needs of his past and being
caught in the past and all of a sudden
there's a car in the distance a
high-pitched car and Kevin jumps up and
it is her babies it is one of her babies
they have found the nest and Kevin is
jubilant and runs off and Russell and
Carl also so excited that I'm gonna be
able to get Kevin home and as they run
over joyed an ominous shadow comes over
them that they don't see right away of
spotlight a very hot blinding spotlight
suddenly turns on and nails Kevin the
bird who freezes in it the evil
adventurer months is huge blimp hovers
above and he's come for Kevin a live
version of That Bird he's got a skeleton
in you know it is if you remember in his
Museum in his blimp
they're all dead things and skeletons
and he always wanted to find a live one
and here's a live one and he's going to
get it in the hovers above and he has
come for Kevin a net thing made of thick
rope shoots out and traps Kevin so Kevin
can't move and Carl works very very fast
to cut him free
get him out of there as quickly as
possible action sequence and in the
meantime you know the off ramp lowers
from the blimp and down comes the evil
adventurer months and his sinister pack
of adversary agent dogs I keep repeating
that because that is it whether they are
dogs or people they are serving the will
of the of the of the adversary and in
these he's made them you know it's a
it's a cartoon it's it's animation and
these these dogs are given the power of
speech so they speak think and be
personified like people but he has a
lantern and to draw Karl away from Kevin
the bird the cruel adventure adventurer
throws the lantern under Ellie's house
to set it on fire this is was a very
startling you know to go this far as I
recall was a very startling thing to see
whether you are adult or a child at the
time the first time you saw it
very cruel and of course in an instant
Carl does not wrestle he cannot wrestle
with this decision he's got to save
Ellie's house it is it is the mausoleum
of all his precious memories and life
with Ellie so he runs to try to save the
house while the dogs run up to Holloway
Kevin the hero pose Ellie's house aloft
it's still just floating you know a few
feet off the ground because the the
balloons are getting tired and losing
helium but he's able to pull it away and
get it away from the fire and he saves
the house but in the meantime months and
his vicious dogs dragged Kevin into the
bowels of the sinister blimp and poor
Russell he's devastated
carl has saved Elly's house but he has
given up Kevin the bird to a cruel fate
and he's obviously he's glad that he
saved the house but he's also feeling
like you know feeling really badly and
crushed Russell says to him you just
gave her away you gave her away that's
how the boy has seen it because he
doesn't understand the pull you know
within within karl and and and his
experience and everything he's lost when
his wife died and the only thing that
really matters to the boy is kevin the
bird and he snaps he gets angry because
of all of this emotion being pressed
down upon him I didn't ask for any of
this Doug the dog tries to soothe Carl
and Carl turns on him bad dog bad dog
okay and that's the end of which your
goal sequence here I don't quite
remember the endangered innocent is is
the story goal actually actually kevin
has been the endangered innocent in this
film for a long time from about the
middle of the of the second act he was
set up to be the endangered innocent
it's been going on for a long time but
now you see a ticking clock has been
sent in motion save him quickly or it's
going to be too late in in a danger of
death or loss absolutely can be one
person or a group one person provides a
strong subplot you better believe it
must be sympathetic oh they come very
few come as sympathetic as Kevin is and
provides the ticking clock so you made
it there are in general between five and
seven main characters in an in movies in
movies that work if you have
as you must have a hero in an adversary
that means you will have three to five
more central characters in order for
your story to work I know there are lots
of students writing scripts who don't
have enough people who don't have enough
of a cast with knowing exactly what
their function is how they are going to
serve this story in one of these
categories but now you get to choose
what kind of story do you want your
story to be okay is a love interest
possible does that work that doesn't
work for all stories you know and you
don't want to push it a lot of people
wait on that a lot of people that it's
tricky to really make that work
so okay a sidekick or no sidekick we're
gonna talk about that a little later
this evening as a matter of fact after
the break but this is it when you know
the paradigm of how the blocks and
pieces of the puzzle fit together and
now you've got this you know what you're
looking for when you are looking to
create characters for your story these
are the character functions that are
served by these by these characters you
may fight it fine if you want to fight
it for a while that's fine by me
try it on I think the more you more
movies you go to the closer you look I
think the more you will see that I am
here to ruin the movies for you at least
for a short while just for a short while
you'll get over it and you will be able
to play that piano like I was a virtuoso
okay any any immediate questions right
now
yeah it's it's usually just one if you
have two people following and doing it's
not a sidekick anymore it's it's a
helper follower to help or follower
characters category from that category
then it's like well like you know uh
Ocean's eleven that hero Danny ocean he
gets a true sidekick who sticks with him
all the time and he's also got all these
helper followers going to so he's got
the whole ball of wax because some plots
require that to rob a casino takes a lot
of people and a lot of different skills
but anything else for now in up Kevin
the bird was is the first of the strange
friends picked up by by Russell he goes
to you know because to do number two and
the bin bushes and he takes he digs the
hole and does all the things they taught
him in camp or school but this huge bird
comes up and eats his candy bar is
chocolate I think he's got or something
like that and and then there's some
comedy and romping with with Carl and
all that stuff but the thing is
immediately after that Doug the dog
shows up and the first thing Doug the
dog says is my master wants me to bring
a bird home I'm going to take this bird
prisoner can I take your bird prisoner
in other words Doug the dog is just the
sweetheart and doesn't know about being
mean but he is telling us from the first
time he arrives which is very shortly
after the time that kevin has arrived
somebody is out to get Kevin and he's
the master my master this and my master
that can I take him home and be a hero
so that is what I mean by its laid in
its laid in early and then during the
midpoint sequence and they're having
dinner with with with months
and there he's just a Karl is just
catching up to the this is not good you
know this is a creepy guy and a creepy
place although he was friendly and they
in the beginning they thought oh okay we
got a new friend but he sees outside the
portholes
he sees Kevin bouncing around having fun
and doing things and then oh my gosh you
know what months sees that Kevin is gone
he's lost right then and there so again
Kevin is at risk and that is one of the
main reasons that they grab and run they
grab Kevin and run and try to get him
out of there and then it goes on and on
and you remember what act what act 3 is
stunning surprise to of up
anybody remember not quite not quite
stunning surprise to of up is when is
when Carl goes outside and Russell has
gotten a few balloons and tied him
around himself and he's got this leaf
blower or something and he's in the air
and his I'm gonna go save Kevin what out
of the blue changes everything here his
life is never gonna be the same again
and then then what does Carl do by then
he has completed his character growth
arc and he gets it the stuff in his
house yes it has sentimental meeting to
him but it's just stuff and he starts
throwing it out in order to lighten the
house so that he can get it back up into
the air again and go save Russell and
Kevin which which he does he takes it's
the the metaphor is so perfect and so
complete all the stuff he has in that
house that means so much to him the
furniture that he throws it all away to
make it into a flying machine you get
yet again to get it in the air and go
after and be the hero who's gonna save
Russell and Kevin and metaphorically he
has finally left the past behind and he
has committed
to a future and then that's in the knack
three is this kind of very lovely and
elongated obligatory seen anything else
for now thank you for your patience I
know this this this was a long one
longer one but there's a lot of juice
here guys there's a lot of things to
think about and to see how all of this
fits together and it's it's really
critical to what we're going to be doing
and what you're going to be doing
starting next semester at least with me
writing a feature film okay take a break
thanks